DAN HEBERDEN: Hello.
As you've been looking at for 15
minutes, I'm Dan Heberden,
so enough about that.
Get my slides up here--
So this is Bower, at least the
very basic beginnings of what
you would start to use,
where you just run
Bower install jquery.
And you see that it went and got
jQuery, installed it for
us in the current folder.
What we didn't have to do
is specify a version.
We didn't have to find out what
the latest version is or
whatever one we wanted.
And what does getting jQuery
look like for you?
Or I mean, really any library,
but jQuery's a good example.
Does that mean going
to jquery.com
and downloading that?
Does mean going to the GitHub
repo and looking for maybe a
built copy?
Do you have to clone the repo
and then build it with their
build tools?
Do you memorize URL and use Wget
or curl to pull it down?
Bower helps because it makes
installing tools much easier,
and it uses a manifest file to
declare what it is that you
actually want to download or
to use in your project.
And all those downloads are
centralized into a common
place, which is very helpful.
And it by itself resolves
dependencies.
Before I get into all the pieces
of what Bower is, I'd
like to show you what it looks
like with a canon of other
tools, a full suite.
And so, Yeoman and Grunt and
Requirejs are great tools.
If you haven't gotten a chance
to look at them or learn about
them, I really recommend
diving into them.
But we're just going to run a
quick example to just show off
some stuff that Bower can do.
First we would do
is get Yeoman.
Yeoman's just a scaffolding
tool that lets you define
some-- there's a couple
generators out there, there's
like 16 that it comes with, and
then a bunch more-- that
help you scaffold typical
applications.
And the typical application
we want to scaffold is a
requirejs app, so we can just
get generator-requirejs.
You can do this yourself, but
it's kind of nice to get
everything all ready to
go without having
to do a lot of work.
I'll show what that
looks like.
Just make a quick--
So assuming that I've gotten
those two things, I can just
run Yeoman with requirejs, and
it'll do a couple things.
It'll ask me some questions,
what I want
the app to be called.
We're just going to make a quick
weather app, so we'll
say my-weather-app, and
a default description.
I'm not going to hit Enter now
just because that's going to
go through and download
everything from MPM, and
everything from Bower, and
everything that we need, and I
don't really trust the Wi-Fi.
So I'm going to just change to
the baked cake in the oven,
and we can see actually--
I'll just do this--
that it already gave us a lot
of stuff just out the gate.
It gave us an app directory
with requirejs config file
that calls the main file here.
It just has jquery in
there, but we can
put anything in there.
But it also did some
other stuff.
It set us up with Grunt, so
we have concatenation and
minification, jshinting
and that kind of
stuff already set up.
It made a package.json, and it
did put our name in there for
us, which is really
convenient.
So just some nice convenience
measures.
Let's go ahead and actually
write some stuff.
Now, for making a weather app,
probably someone has done the
work of getting weather.
I'm sure actually thousands of
people have probably done that
all by theirself without
even looking to see if
anyone has done that.
So let's just use Bower, and
we'll search for weather.
Let me make that a little
bit bigger.
So it looks like
Dan Heberden--
I don't know who that guy is--
but he made a weather thing, and
I'm going to trust it for
the sake of this presentation.
So I can just use Bower to
install weather, and I'll save
that to my configuration file.
If you've used MPM, that's
the same kind of thing.
We'll talk more about what
these pieces mean.
But you see here that it went
and it got the weather
component, but then it also got
the stuff that component
needs, which is jQuery.
And so now, if I go back to my
application here, I not only
have the things that were part
of the original application,
requirejs and jquery and qunit,
but I also have my
weather module.
So let's go ahead
and use that.
Since this is an AMD module,
I'll just hop over into my
main file here, and I can just
reference it directly.
Let me hop back to my slides.
That is not the right slide.
There we go, OK.
So in our app, we would put us
in some HTML for our actual
weather information, just the
temperature and status, that
kind of stuff.
And then inside of that, we can
use that whether component
that we installed.
So we'll just use require to get
that and typical AMD stuff
here, so nothing too crazy,
and make a function that
actually uses the position
object that the weather API
returns with temperature,
and condition, and
that kind of stuff.
And then actually get our
current position.
So we'll use geolocation, get
our current position, and pump
that latitude and longitude
into our weather module.
I have the finished product
here, and hopefully this will
work with the connection.
So I have a connect server
actually part of this whole
suite here, which is
nice, via Grunt.
So I can start a web server
on local hosts.
You see here that that worked
pretty well out of the box,
and was able to make a network
connection, do all that stuff.
But we didn't have to worry
about finding this module and
putting it in.
We were just able to take
advantage of it.
Let's look at what actually
happened here.
This is the bower.json
that was generated
from what we did.
And we have a requirejs and
jQuery dependencies that came
out of the box.
But when we installed weather,
it also added
that version here.
The tilde means it's going to
keep the minor version.
So if that goes to
0.2.4, it'll go
ahead and install that.
We looked at a quick demo of
what that can look like using
that with other tools.
I do want to show you one really
neat thing, since I
have this up, and that
is using all
of these tools together.
And this is mostly just a plug
for Grunt and how well it does
all of this stuff.
I just ran every task that
set up with this.
So I'm hinting, I'm running my
test suite, I'm getting all of
the dependencies via requirejs
and putting them all together,
and now I'm concatenating and
minifying all of that together.
So my original, uncompressed
file of 326K is now 23K.
That's pretty cool.
So if you aren't doing this or
haven't looked in these kind
of tools, I highly suggest
doing that.
One HTTP request just to get
all of the site running,
that's pretty neat.
Why a client-side
package manager?
Well, using client-side
tools should be easy.
I mean, sure, going the
hotscripts.com and finding
some script was really
fun 10 years ago.
There's a problem with open
and public code being
committed into repositories.
And I don't know about you,
but I don't really like
waiting for GitHub to
download gargantuous
repositories all the time.
But what happens is older and
buggy versions of libraries or
frameworks or plug-ins get stuck
in projects, and it's
harder to work around getting
a new one in there.
And then there's a hesitancy
to use an existing solution
because it's kind of
a pain to go out
and find what's available.
And when you do you find out
that there's a great plug-in
or piece, you have to go find
out what it needs to run, and
that can be a big hassle.
But Bower, of course, makes it
awesome, hence this talk.
So let's look into Bower.
Let's look at what pieces that
it has that will help you.
So we saw installation before.
We could just install a
component, and it'll go ahead
and grab all of that stuff.
It'll grab all the pieces,
put that into our folder.
We can also do that
via manifest file.
So we can declare what we want,
run Bower install, and
it'll just go through that
manifest file just like MPM
and get the pieces that are
required, along with anything
that those pieces require, and
anything that those pieces
require, until it has everything
that you need.
And of course, if you edit the
manifest file, we want to
change this.
Say there was a bug, and we want
to force version 0.2.0,
we can do that.
And run Bower install, and it'll
go get the right files,
and make sure everything's OK
as far as dependencies go.
Now, if you want to do this from
the command line, you can
do that pretty easily just by
putting in the module name
that you want, and then a hash
mark, and then the version.
And that'll do the same thing,
if you need to do that from
the command line.
So in this case, we want jQuery
1.8.0, and so we can
force that.
And you can manually edit it.
That's fine.
But we have this same as MPM,
--save, and --savedev.
And those let you just express
what you want to install, but
also put that into your manifest
file, because chances
are you not only want that now,
you're going to want that
any time you recreate this
project or someone else clones
this project and gets that.
But at this point, Bower
is mostly just a
glorified URL shortener.
Like this is nice, but this
isn't what's really
going to help you.
And so upgrading is where Bower
also shines in making
your life a lot easier in
dealing with client-side
libraries and frameworks
and plug-ins.
Since required packages don't
have to be committed into your
repository, it makes
discoverability and it makes
working with these libraries
much easier.
Check out Bower ls.
It gives you a quick look at
what your current project
looks like.
And so in this case, we just
installed jquery 1.8.0.
It's going to let us know that
2.0.0 is out, and that we
could look into upgrading
to that.
We didn't have to the jQuery
site or make sure that we
follow the blog.
And this is for any particular
plug-in or
piece that you follow.
But it also hunts down the
dependencies just to make sure
that everything's fine as far
as what it requires as well.
So we have a nice map of what
our project looks like.
Bower update will take the
current version, install it to
the highest minor version
possible.
So in this case, it'll
go to 1.8.3.
And that's nice if you want to
just make sure that while
there shouldn't be any problems,
run the test suite,
give it a run through, and then
make sure that you can
deploy your site using these
latest versions.
Let's talk about the power of
bower.json, having something
that expresses your client-side
needs in your
application.
And the easiest way to do that
is this, just obliterate the
components directory.
And of course, this would
cripple your app altogether,
and it's just as easy as running
Bower install to get
all of that stuff back.
Now Bower is just a
package manager.
Bower doesn't give you
minified code.
Bower doesn't concatenate
things.
It doesn't load modules
for you, and it won't.
You say what you want,
and Bower gets it.
Because there's plenty of
great tools out there.
There's tons of build tools.
There's tons of things to help
you do certain tasks.
Bower doesn't need to
do that for you.
But what it does need to do
is play well with others.
And so since it's written in
JavaScript, and since it's a
node library, you can just
require it and do the same
things that you can do from
the command line.
Search, install, look at what
packages are available, and
control it from maybe a
custom build tool that
you have, or Grunt.
Another thing that is really
nice and available for you is
a plug-in that Ben Schwarz
made for Sublime Text.
I'm not a Sublime Text user, so
I might bumble around this
a little bit, but I wanted
to show you what
this could look like.
Actually, let me do
that from here.
And we'll go in here--
So here's a typical
Sublime project.
And the typical way that you
run the built-in tools,
Command-Shift-P, when
you install this
tool, it adds a Bower--
you can't really change the
font, unfortunately, of that
particular part of Sublime.
I don't think so.
Nope.
But what it lists there, if
you can't see it, is Bower
Install, Bower Configure
Project, and
Bower Discover Packages.
And so from here, I could run
Bower Install, and that gives
me kind of an interactive
search.
So I could look for "angular,"
and find that package and
install it right from Sublime.
So I don't even have to hop
into the command line if I
don't want to.
Of course, if you have Little
Snitch running, it'll ask you
every time, if that's OK.
So just from Sublime, I was able
to add something into my
bower.json file, and it
downloaded it into my
components directory where
I have Angular now.
So that's pretty nice, but
there's another tool that this
exposes, or links to, rather,
which is Discover Packages.
And so Cinder made this,
Cinder Source
on GitHub and Twitter.
And this is a search website for
Bower where you can take a
look, and we can do the same
thing, angular, and get some
of available metrics about what
matched that search, when
it was last updated, how
many forks and stars.
A little bit more information
to help you make a good
decision about what piece
you want to add in
and discover things.
Currently, there's 2,048, so
exactly 2K components, which
is fantastic.
Let's look at the Angular
stuff just really quick.
I have a quick demo about what
that can look like if you want
to require jsfan.
or if you just, like, Angular.
Where did that go?
There we go.
So we're making a typical
Angular app.
We have our name space in the
HTML, myApp, and starting with
the basic template of HTML.
And we'll go and install
that Angular
component that's available.
So add our Angular script into
our project, and then add some
basic module code.
So we'll depend on myApp,
and create a controller.
And this is going to make
an itemized list.
So we see the UL
up at the top.
It's going to make just a
repeatable list item based off
of this item list.
But let's say that we want to
make this actually work with
Markdown instead.
And I'm sure that there's some
kind of Markdown Angular thing
that's existing out there, so
we can search for "angular"
and just parse out anything that
mentions "markdown." And
we could have also used
this website here
or use Sublime Text.
We could Bower install,
angular markdown.
It brings up the same thing.
So whichever way you choose
to get there, you can.
And so at the end of the day,
we install that that Angular
Markdown directive, and we see
the it installed Showdown.
That's what it requires for
the Markdown parsing.
And then we have Angular, of
course, which is the directive
piece, or what it depends
on to actually run.
We already installed that,
so it doesn't matter.
So now we have our three
components that we need to
add, which is Angular itself,
the Markdown parser, and then
the Angular Markdown
directive.
We can add that module
now as a dependency.
It's already been included
as a script
tag, so it's now available.
So we can include it just like
we would in a regular app.
Make sure that we specify that
this item will be parsed using
that with the btf-markdown
here, the
latter part of the li.
And then just add
some Markdown.
So in this case, on the last
item, we're just making that
some pretty basic Markdown.
And what that looks like--
this is the full HTML.
Whoa, that got really big.
This is the full HTML that we
have now that was generated.
These are our components
all installed--
Angular, Angular Markdown
directive, and Showdown.
Bower is updated with the
two pieces that we need.
And there it's running those
three items through the
generator, and it is
parsing Markdown.
So that didn't take a
lot of work to go
hunt down these pieces.
And imagine that part where you
find out, yes, there's an
Angular directive for
parsing Markdown.
Oh, now I need to get Showdown,
and now I need to
find out where they put
their build file.
And you're well aware that that
could be on their website.
That could be in some dist
folder in their GitHub repo,
or maybe it's the source file,
but you're not quite sure
which one it is.
And that gets really
complicated, and that takes
time, and that is a barrier
of entry to use
that particular plug-in.
But that also is just time that
you don't need to spend.
There's also a really nice
ability of being able to work
with a directory that's
managed by a tool.
And that is, if we go back
to our step three here--
so I have my bower.json file.
If I want to see what my app
looks like with a particular
piece, I can just install
any version I want.
If I want to test [INAUDIBLE]
requirejs 3.0 comes out, and I
want to test that with my
application, I can just
install that using Bower.
And if my whole app just
completely explodes, or I find
a bug and so I report it to
requirejs, or I install jQuery
2.0.1 and I find a bug,
I can report that bug.
I can help the community.
I can help those projects
that I depend on.
But then I can just switch back
to the version that I
need, and it wasn't
a big deal.
I didn't have to rename
to jquery.old.js and
put in the new one.
And if you've ever done that,
and I know you have, you don't
have to anymore.
So we never had to hunt
down Angular.
Able to find everything
really easy.
And most of all, the scripts
are in a consistent place.
So we looked at the requirejs
demo earlier, and now I was
using components as the full
path, components weather and
then weather.js.
There's a Grunt contribution
plug-in for that that actually
adds those to your path
automatically.
So I could have just had jquery
and weather, and it
would have just worked.
So there's tools out there.
Bower has a lot of pieces to
integrate with Rails, with
different build tools.
There's a lot of community
around making it integrate
with whatever work process
that you have.
So what's coming up?
There's a lot of great stuff
that we looked out, but
obviously there's room
for improvement.
We're not perfect.
This is still a new project.
And so some of the things
that we want to
do are hosted packages.
We want you to be able to
authenticate with the
registration server, and so
we've started work on this, so
that you could go in and rename
a package if you added
one or delete it.
You'd be able to push a copy of
a built file if you don't
want that, maybe, in
your repository.
So you could push that
up to us directly.
And of course, we could
give a cached copy.
So if you don't have Git or you
want that even faster, we
can just push the file
that you want down,
which is really helpful.
Andre, who is the lead developer
for Bower, Marco and
him have been working on a
rewrite of Bower to make it
faster, to make it easier for
us to work on, and to add to
better features.
This a quick video he made.
Let me go full screen here.
I'm going to probably
pause it.
It's a really short video.
So this is his dependencies
list, and these
are pretty big pieces.
It needs a lot of pieces.
So this is a pretty indicative
of a typical, real-world app
as far as how many components
are there.
What he has here is, on the
left, is going to be with the
rewrite, and then on the right
is the current version.
And so those run.
Bower just goes to town
getting everything.
So you see on the left is
already much faster.
It was able to get all of that
content in just 8.8 seconds,
whereas the current one is 13.
And then if you have cache,
which Bower has, once you've
actually done this once, most
of these repos are probably
using across different projects,
it's now down to 2.3
seconds versus 5.7 on
the current version.
And then that time you're on
a plane, and you need to
recreate the project, and
you know you have all
that cached, 1 second.
So this isn't a big commitment
as far as having a process
around getting these packages.
Running even on the current
version, it's
still pretty fast.
And it's only going to get
faster, and it's only going to
get better.
And so working this tool into
your workflow not only should
make your life easier, but it
should do a faster job of
hunting down all these
things for you than
you possibly could.
And as developers, that's
the whole point.
And of course, we're working
on the regular stuff.
So more docs, less bugs.
Unless you want more bugs.
I guess we could put them in.
And more packages, and
more integration.
And that's really the biggest
piece of this, is we want to
make Bower something that is
extendable to work with any
tools, and we can just write
whatever middleware, whatever
plug-ins to make it work so that
you can take advantage of
it in the way that
you see fit.
And we can focus on just getting
packages, getting
stuff for you, in a sane way.
But we need help with that.
We need help on Bower.
We need help with
these pieces.
And so github.com/bower, all the
pieces that we're working
on, are there.
Bower IRC channel on freenode,
definitely come in and chat
with us, and let us
know if you're
running into any problems.
We have a Bower Google group.
And that's it.
The timer was going pretty
crazy, so I'm not sure exactly
what it all means for
time, but I think I
have time for questions.
[APPLAUSE]
DAN HEBERDEN: I should note,
too, that if you want to, we
have a bunch of Bower
stickers.
And if you liked the logo, which
is pretty new, by Dave
DeSandro, pretty neat logo.
So if you want to sport that
on your laptop or child's
forehead, definitely come up
and get a Bower sticker.
Go ahead?
AUDIENCE: So this is awesome,
really awesome.
I'm looking forward to it.
I haven't used it yet, but I
definitely would love to start
using it some of my projects.
This does all the client-side
components and so on, and
usually all our projects have
server-side and client-side
together as their--
is there any sort of integration
between different
kinds of server-side packaging
systems as
well, or packages that--
DAN HEBERDEN: The integration,
that's where we want to make
sure that, as a developer,
you're the
one calling the shots.
And so a good demo of this is
actually this presentation,
which ended up not working that
great because there's a
lot of network connections
in here.
But I wanted to hook up my phone
so that I could have the
next slide show up on
my phone, and so I
wanted to use Socket.IO.
And so looking at that, I was
like, well, I better use of
Bower because I'm writing
a talk about Bower.
And so if I have my node
modules, I have Socket.IO.
So in this case, I know I need
Socket.IO on the server, so I
just add that to my
package.json, and then Bower
search socket.
Give you a few different ones
that are available, and you
can see that there's a client
available to get.
So it's still going to be two
separate pieces because
they're going to be two
different libs but having the
ability to hop between the two
really easily and just have
MPM install and Bower install
as part of your process.
And when I showed Yeoman
earlier, that actually runs
both for you as well.
So even if you're building
something that scaffolds an
app that you maybe build often,
you can have that as
part of your workflow of just,
OK, here's my server-side
components, here's all my
client-side components, go.
AUDIENCE: I guess we
can always script.
Like if you want just a single
install, get everything
running from scratch or
whatever, script that, and
then you can script these
components as well.
DAN HEBERDEN: Yes.
That's why I look at Yeoman
generators or something
similar to do that.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: I had a question.
We use Bower at our company,
and one thing I noticed is
that when you Bower install
something like Bootstrap, you
get like 15 ls files and 15 js
files, and it's not built.
Is there any way to integrate
with Bower to have it
automatically build that as
soon as I download it?
I mean, some packages actually
do have the build files in the
source, but I'm just looking for
a way to kind of improve
that workflow, I guess.
DAN HEBERDEN: Yeah.
So Bower won't be the tool that
builds that, because you
can imagine that might be a
make file-- in the case of
Bootstrap, it is a make file--
that could be node, whatever.
So there needs to be
a way to make that
build version available.
Now the way that Bootstrap does
it, they actually hide it
in the Docs folder.
So if you go into Docs, that's
where the built js
and CSS files are.
What we've been working on is
there's a main property inside
of Bower's manifest file, and
so we're working on the spec
to bring that to more light so
that the actual file that you
want is not only highlighted to
you, here it is, but even
like possibly moved to
root, or something
that makes that easier.
And also the hosted part will
mean that if you have a
complicated build process, you
can publish your built copy if
you don't want that
in your repo.
Like I like it in the repo.
I think that's a cool thing.
But obviously not everyone
agrees with me.
So we're working on
that for sure.
AUDIENCE: Great, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Can I use my own modules that
are not in that directory, for
example, in the Bower file?
DAN HEBERDEN: Yeah.
So if there's something that,
like, maybe in a corporate
environment, you don't want to
publish certain things, or you
have private code, you can
reference any Git repository
and just specify the
Git URL and a tag.
So actually when I was working
on this-- so codemirror is, I
was like, man, I really don't
want to have to commit this in
the project.
And then of course, I clicked,
I'm writing a talk of about
Bower, so I could use that.
And I was just able to point
it to the Git repo for
codemirror, and it just
pulled it for me.
So even without someone going
through the work of making
their project Bower-compatible,
I was still
able to just throw it in
there and use that.
So you could use that and
specify a tag if you wanted to
for a specific version
of that.
AUDIENCE: On the server-side,
you have the luxury of if two
modules require the same thing
but have different version
requirements, you can just load
them as dependencies of
the dependencies, and each
one gets called in
for the correct spot.
On the client, you can't run
jQuery 1.4.2 for one module
and 2.0 for another module.
So what's the solution on the
client-side for mismatched
dependencies?
DAN HEBERDEN: That will show up
in the bower.ls, but it's
going to ultimately be your
decision to mitigate that.
Because like you said, there's
no just easy way out.
And so that's where you making
the decision of what to do, in
which library is going to be the
correct one or will work.
We're working on finding out
the best way to do that.
Like should our process stop all
together, and say there's
a conflict, and you have
to resolve this first?
Or should we just carry on and
hope that you can figure it
out yourself?
So we're working on some better
feedback on that, but
it'll still show you that we
have two different versions,
and you're going to
have to figure out
which one to put in.
But that's where, again, the
developer needs to be the
decision maker, and Bower
doesn't need to be a tool that
forces you into a box in
particular situations.
Because you might be very well
aware, oh, this person just
didn't update their
dependency list.
I guess that's it for questions,
so thank you very
much for you attention.
And come get a sticker
if you want.
[APPLAUSE]